pas expliquer le contexte aussi une
cinquantaine de manifestants en lock-out
de chronos une compagnie de varennes
s'est présenté ce matin vers 6h30 chez
robert transport parce que robert
transport effectué des transports de
matières premières vers la compagnie
chronos et les manifestants font aller
justement manifester leur mécontentement
la compagnie parce qu'ils sont en
lock-out il ne voulait pas que le
transport se poursuivre malgré le
lock-out et est arrivé un incident vous
allez le voir sur les images je voulais
bien alors ils étaient une cinquantaine
de manifestants il ya un travailleur de
transport robert s'est présenté sur
place
on le voit il y à l'intérieur de son
camion le camion de type ford explorer
et il décide d'avancer quand même à une
vitesse quand même assez élevées vers
les manifestants
alors on voit que manifestants qui est
demeuré coincé sous la roue avant gauche
il est resté là plusieurs minutes le
temps que les secours arrivent et il a
été blessé c'est un homme de 64 ans donc
l'été il a perdu connaissance pour ce
qu'on voit qu'il ne bouge plus une fois
qu'ils étaient sortis avec grâce à
l'aide des pompiers il a été transporté
à l'hôpital où il a subi des blessures
au visage des brûlures également une
lacération on nous dit tout de même que
son état de santé va bien on ne craint
pas pour sa vie pour le moment mais
quand même il a été blessé
après donc cet événement il ya eu une
autre personne qui a été blessée au bras
on la voyait dans la vidéo est également
il ya deux personnes qui ont été traités
pour choc nerveux
alors on vient toujours d'obtenir en
exclusivité ces images qui ont été
captées par des manifestants qui étaient
sur place
alors on comprend un peu plus la faim
dans lequel le conducteur du camion est
présentement interrogé par les
enquêteurs du service de police de
longueuil
est-ce qu'il sera accusé d'agression
armée ça reste à voir pour l'instant il
est toujours interrogé donc par ces
enquêteurs et on a eu vraiment deux
versions simon faut le mentionner ce
côté du syndicat on nous disait que
l'homme a foncé délibérément sur les
manifestants et du côté de la porte
parole de transport robert on nous a dit
que c'était un accident que l'homme ait
glissé sous le camion alors je vous
laisse vous faire votre propre opinion
lorsque vous regardez ces images on
n'était pas là mais quand on regarde les
images on comprend un peu plus ce qui a
pu bien pu se produire donc ce matin
vers 6h50
à boucherville le tout près de
l'entreprise robert transport